At the end of the day what we want is an equation of motion
describing how these masses will accelerate.
Before we jumped into solving the problem, there's still a little more benefit
we can get from doing more thought experiments.
Let's see what will happen when M₂ is much bigger than M₁, for example may be
M₂ is a grand piano and M₁ is a slice of apple pie.
This is a sort of silly example but I'm trying to make a somewhat serious point.
We can push nature to its limits in our head but we never have to set up this experiment.
We just have to think what's going to happen.
Well, we already know when M₂ is greater than M₁, the system accelerates clockwise, of course.
The piano pulls more than the pie, of course.
In fact, when M₂ is so much bigger than M₁, we can even estimate its acceleration.
So in this situation now, I want you to tell me--what do you think is the best estimate
for how quickly this piano works all the way downwards and
therefore, how quickly the pie works all the way upwards.
Is it 10, 5, 2 or 1 m/s².
Now, I want you to remember that a free falling object accelerates downwards at 10 m/s².